economía en france 24 está conmigo en el
estudio daniela blandón daniela muy
buenas noches comenzamos hablando de
tasas de desempleo del 2020 en américa
latina méxico es el primer país que las
da a conocer si santiago muy buenas muy
buenas noches miren la oficina de
estadísticas de méxico dice que la tasa
de desempleo en el 2020 fue del 38 por
ciento esto equivale a un punto
porcentual por encima del 2.9 por ciento
que había registrado el país en 2019 en
números absolutos esto quiere decir que
12 millones de personas salieron del
mercado laboral en abril y sólo 9.5
millones se han reintegrado pero
santiago aquí hay que hacer también una
acotación es que en méxico hay demasiada
informalidad se estima que una de cada
dos personas es informal pero porque no
le damos un vistazo a la región miren
según la comisión económica para américa
latina y el caribe 31,2 millones de
personas abandonaron sus puestos de
trabajo el año pasado por culpa de la
pandemia y la tasa de desempleo que
venía de un 64 por ciento en 2000
ha venido subiendo hasta dispararse al
10 7 % al cierre del año pasado pero la
cepal también cree que el 2020 cerró con
230 millones de pobres en américa latina
y la pandemia es el responsable de por
lo menos 45 millones de ellos y además
96 millones de personas están en la
pobreza extrema hablemos ahora del fondo
monetario internacional que se está
moviendo con fuerza en varios países de
américa latina' conversando con sus
respectivos gobiernos sí señor este
jueves el presidente argentino alberto
fernández tuvo una videoconferencia con
la jefa del fondo monetario
internacional kristalina georgieva para
seguir trabajando en la refinanciación
de la deuda este país tiene una deuda de
44 mil millones de dólares con el
organismo internacional que adquirió
durante el gobierno de mauricio macri
pues alberto fernández siempre ha
tildado el organismo de ser uno de los
responsables de la crisis y dijo que sin
embargo está dispuesto a honrar ese
compromiso pero bajo nuevas y mejores
condiciones que son las que se están
justo
negociando el fondo también se está
moviendo por otros países hoy por
ejemplo panamá asegura un crédito por
casi 3 mil millones de dólares y costa
rica está a punto de firmar uno por mil
750 millones de dólares también hay que
así santiago que el motivo por el cual
los ciudadanos por lo general se oponen
al fondo monetario internacional es
porque esos préstamos incluyen agresivos
programas fiscales con aumentos de
impuestos y eliminación de subsidios
entre otros
pasamos ahora a hablar de la ocde que
reaccionó ante la posición del nuevo
presidente de eeuu joe biden y el
también conocido como club de países
ricos dijo que si se concretan las
medidas que está impulsando el nuevo
presidente de eeuu el crecimiento a
corto plazo será mucho mayor para este
año el organismo estima un alza del 3 5%
pero confía en que los planes como el
paquete de estímulos darán un impulso
adicional uno de los temas más urgentes
en la agenda tiene que ser sí o sí el
empleo en la última semana de las
peticiones de subsidios fueron de
900.000 que es una
todavía muy alta si se compara con las
200 mil solicitudes semanales que se
registraban antes de la pandemia y
pasemos a este tema bonito una nota de
color
daniela y es que en italia señal
sellaron hoy las primeras monedas de las
gracias de qué se trata santiago se
trata de una moneda de dos euros que
representa una conmemoración muy
particular escuche vamos ha estado esta
desgracia se dejamos del año pasado nos
vimos muy afectados por esta tragedia
del cobi 19 por lo que el ministerio de
economía decidió admitir una moneda
conmemorativa para agradecer a todos los
trabajadores de la salud que se han
esforzado tanto por nosotros elaborar el
suave por la salud de honor y el diseño
elaborado por la casa de la moneda
muestra trabajadores de la salud hombre
y mujer con mascarillas y la palabra
grasa que significa gracias entre mayo y
junio serán distribuidos tres millones
de ejemplares
incluso algunos estarán disponibles para
comprarlos como artículos de colección
hablemos ahora de los indicadores como
las ffaa las principales bolsas en la
jornada de hoy segundo récord seguido
para dos de los índices más importantes
de wall street el estándar
y el nasdaq en europa hubo augurios
negativos del banco central y por eso
las bolsas bajaron y en américa latina
un fuerte descenso en argentina cifra
del día para el cierre hasta 8 mil 800
dólares de multas que cobrará reino
unido a quienes participen en fiestas de
más de 15 personas durante el actual
confinamiento mire si usted es
descubierto en una fiesta ilegal lo
multan con 800 libras pero si lo vuelven
a sorprender pues le ponen más multa
gracias daniela grazie mille muchas
gracias a ustedes por la sintonía sigan
france24
[Música]